vegas now the win is inviting you to get
wild on the strip the immersive four-day
music festival art of the wild is back
starting this weekend and mariana albano
of wynn nightlife is here to tell us
what to expect welcome hi
you're wearing your animal print for the
art of the watch we are ready yeah it's
a full week i mean we prepare all the
way from the beginning of the week so
we're ready to go well we were just
talking about how much we love the win
no bias i love the winners my favorite
property um you guys do everything with
just top tier so let's talk about art of
the wild what should we expect what is
it yeah so it is a four day music
festival um this weekend so it starts on
friday goes through monday
it is at our famous encore beach club of
course and access nightclub and it's
just really fun it's immersive
experience and you get to really
see the venues in a different way um
encore beach club has a ton of like
decor we put a truss structure over the
pool wow we're seeing a video of it
right now yeah it's really cool elrow is
really fun and then at xs we just fully
immersive from the time you step through
the front door there's just all these
different lighting elements and all this
like extra stuff that you won't see on a
normal weekend and monday is really fun
our la salva party is completely outside
so it's a totally different experience
than when you're there
from weekend to weekend wow so you guys
are it's the night life club it's a
nightclub and it's the day club yeah so
you're getting two different experiences
throughout the entire property
absolutely you can really come for the
full weekend you can stay in our
luxurious rooms dine at our wonderful
restaurants go to our day club then go
to our nightclub so it's really cool you
can make a whole weekend out of it and
this is your fifth installment of the
festival that is how it started back in
2018. 2018 was the first one yeah so
how's it evolved what can what's so
special about this year in particular um
this year what's really cool i think
particularly is our friday is gonna
start at encore beach club okay by the
time encore beach club will wrap up
it'll go straight into excess oh my god
so you can
split all day yeah so it's basically a
full day party that will start during
the day and then go to about six a.m so
we're going hard on friday we're going
to start the weekend off right okay and
you personally you've been involved with
this event you know what are you looking
forward to the most what is your
favorite part of this event that's tough
i would say um the production okay it's
really fun the from the costumes to the
decor elements to the performers we have
it's just really like everything comes
alive it's so much fun yeah and happy
people get tickets and join you guys
nightlife.com we have everything there
yeah tickets and we actually hand out
wristbands it's really fun because it
makes it feel like a festival yeah and
okay what can people wear
to this dress like a festival okay it's
a little relaxed um daytime even night
time the excess dress code is a little
bit more relaxed we really want you to
feel like you're at a festival okay okay
but thank you yeah absolutely thanks for
having me all right the art of the wild
music festival is happening this weekend
starting march 18th taking place at
encore beach club and access nightclub
for more information again just head to
winsocial.com ted are you going
what do you think i'm getting tickets